[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kay Bhd here and
for the past couple of days since WWDC I
keep getting asked about my thoughts
obviously on iOS 7 because it's the
biggest change to iOS since the original
iPhone and I also keep hearing one
phrase a lot I owe s copied Android iOS
copied Android iOS copied Android but to
be honest it's not just Android and some
features are just too good not to be
shared so without any further ado this
is where iOS features come from all the
new features of iOS 7 and their origin
now the easiest place to start is of
course the lock screen and the lock
screen is what's most visually similar
to what we saw in first and Android 4.0
Ice Cream Sandwich last year first of
all iOS this new lock screen has a new
wallpaper and it has a new light font
and the new wallpaper it has is animated
so they demonstrated it in the keynote
when you move your phone around it moves
wallpaper on with it animated wallpapers
believe it or not originated in Windows
Vista and a mode called dream scene in
2006 so pcs had basically the ability to
have movies instead of images as their
wallpapers this wasn't all that popular
but this was first brought to mobile
devices in the form of live wallpapers
on Android and this gave the ability to
not only have moving pictures as your
wallpaper but you could actually
interact with them and have them respond
to your sensors like your gyroscope your
accelerometer and sometimes even to
touch so Apple's iOS 7 wallpaper
movement is called parallax according to
them and it basically moves around and
reveals more parts of the image as you
move around the gyroscope so response to
that particular sensor it's actually an
app in the Google Play Store right now
that will allow you to do the same thing
on an Android device should you feel so
inclined I also hope that you have the
ability to turn this off in iOS because
I can see that getting annoying for a
lot of people with very specific
wallpaper habits or OCD like me but once
of course you bypassed that new lock
screen you will get to the overall new
look of Iowa 7 first thing that'll
strike you is the new icons and the new
flatter more modern look of all the
different applications which no doubt
take inspiration from a ton of places
including Apple's own designers and I
think Windows Phone is probably one of
the major inspirations for that it's a
very simple operating system very very
simple look up top even though there's a
lot of complicated things going on below
but I like the fact that it looks more
with less leather and green felt and
stitching going on that's a welcome not
addition in iOS 7 so the weather app in
iOS 7 has been redesigned and they would
a Naga crowd with of course some new
weather animations so when you swipe
between different locations
it'll animate you and give you basically
a look at what the weather looks like in
real time this was first seen three
years ago when HTC Sense first came out
which is yes on top of Android in the
HTC Desire and that's where you could
first open up the weather app and get
again a full screen preview of real-time
weather animation and on iOS 7 I also
like that the new calendar looks very
clean that's probably my favorite new
redesigned app of all the ones in iOS 7
the calendar app takes a lot of
inspiration from the new OS 10 mavericks
calendar and whole bunch of other
different things it looks very good very
flat very modern look like it could
belong on any modern phone to be honest
and that's saying something so that's a
good redesign probably my favorite new
app on the iPhone actually now these
swipe gestures these swipe gestures from
left to right that are being introduced
in some of the new apps in iOS 7 like
calendar and messages these are new
these we've seen also first in Google
apps on Android started with the Google
Plus app started actually with Google
Plus app and now it's in a bunch of
other apps the Google Drive app the
hangouts app the YouTube app all these
apps give you the ability to swipe in
from the side and it's very good with
functionality where you want to use a
one-handed use on a big phone you can't
necessarily all the way reach up into
the corner every single time so that's
good blackberry hub also uses that swipe
in from the side where you can view all
of your different notifications and
things like that so this has been
something that's been around for a while
as Google starts to permeate through its
ecosystem one by one the different apps
iOS 7 looks like it'll just jump that
whole boat and just put it in all the
different apps in iOS 7
now the categorized Notification Center
in iOS 7 is actually pretty unique it's
really interesting it actually first
appeared in a butdo phone interestingly
enough so that swipe down from the top
notification is in a ton of different
mobile operating systems but the ability
to swipe horizontally or at least move
from left to right to change what your
Notification Center looks like is pretty
much from Ubuntu phone now a butdo phone
lets you swipe left to right to adjust
those toggles but again it's the
horizontal or a lateral organization of
that swipe down notification tray that
is where they're getting that from now
Apple is of course
has their own touch to it has their own
look their own feel their own categories
and I think it'll work well with people
who are already using iPhones and iPads
but again yeah that's where I came from
also the ability to access your
notifications from the lock screen is
new to iOS this is not new to Android
wear it was first seen in Android 4.0
again from last year control center in
iOS it is a mush of a ton of different
things from a ton of different places
it's new to iOS basically you can swipe
up from the bottom of your phone and get
a panel where you can control a whole
bunch of different settings toggles this
was first seen in Android 4.2 so it's
also very recent but Android 4.2 you can
have to tap twice to get to it or swipe
down with two fingers from your
notification bar with Apple you can
swipe up with one finger from the bottom
which lets you get to with one hand and
of course it's got a totally different
look from anywhere else so I give them
design props for that it's also
transparent on top of whatever app you
happen to be looking at so if you open
it on top of the calendar it has that
interesting look if it opens it on top
of the calculator or maybe on top of a
game it'll have a different look
altogether I don't know what it looks
like in landscape but again we'll find
that out pretty much very soon and
obviously the transparency is something
as varied between different mobile
operating systems if you look at early
versions of Android the versions of
transparency have changed back and forth
it's been either totally opaque or very
transparent more recently it's been
almost completely opaque but not quite
Apple takes it to the very very very
glossy glossy sort of look now iOS 7
finally brings real multitasking to the
iPhone and iPad and it does this in the
form of a cards UI now we've seen real
multitasking on a bunch of different
other operating systems apples claims to
do it in a much smarter way in terms of
utilizing CPU cycles in order to make
the best of battery life but the actual
interface itself brings us back to webOS
which was around 2009 with the Palm Pre
and the palm pixi so that is taken its
way back again Matias Duarte who you may
not know was actually one of the
designers of webOS was also one of the
designers for Android when he moved to
Android and they started designing
Android 4.2 and 4.1 that's where they
got that look from for the new Galaxy
Nexus and Nexus 4 stuff so that design
is pretty much all over the place now
but
cards UI originated with webOS Safari
also got some improvements from iOS 7 it
got a full-screen look a smart search
field tab switching interface and
favorite pages just like Chrome for
Android however chrome was gotten these
features one by one over the course of
about two years or so as it's been
introduced to Android Safari I just got
these all dumped in at once so obviously
it has the same exact feature set being
added but it's just all dumped in at the
same time nice now here's a feature
that's unique to iOS airdrop it's
basically Wi-Fi sharing it's unique to
iOS because it's the proprietary
technology they've been using on Macs
for a while so it originated in OS 10
now it's in OS 10 mavericks and you can
now share those same files with anyone
on the network who has an iPad or an
iPhone as well so obviously no NFC love
needed for the next iPhone they might
have NFC in the next iPhone but they did
kind of make a play on words onstage
about how hey there's no need to go
bumping your phone around with people
play on the galaxy s4 commercials but
that originated in OS 10 the camera and
iOS also got a lot of nice improvements
you can swipe from the video camera to
the photo camera to the Instagram I mean
square camera and to the panoramic
camera and of course that's actually
kind of unique to iOS and you also have
the ability to add live filters and
these live filters that were usually
added originally digitally in digital
cameras from around 2006 then it was
made popular by photobooth of course on
Mac OS 10 and I think that's where they
got the main inspiration from it and now
of course live filters are on all types
of devices on iOS and Android alike
apple also is finally taking control of
what used to be the endless stream of
photos from your photo gallery in iOS
and in other operating systems including
Windows Phone and Android and Blackberry
for a while now you've had the ability
to sort your photo albums by location or
by tags or by people in them or by time
or by albums Apple is going to now just
do that for you they're going to sort by
time and location and give you the
ability to zoom in or out on what they
call moments and scenes and basically
let you look through your photo gallery
that way it's Apple's way you don't get
to choose which albums are where but you
definitely get
a much more organized view of where your
pictures have been taken and ios7 also
now has a bunch of Siri improvements
with an all-new creepily accurate and
natural female voice and male voice hi
what can I do for you hi Eddie
what can I do for you sir he also has a
support for a few new languages now and
also has the ability to change system
settings which is a first as far as I've
seen so you can now turn on Wi-Fi or
turn off Bluetooth or turn down
brightness just by telling Siri to do so
you also now have integration with
Twitter and Wikipedia in your search
results and you also now have direct
integration with Bing in your search
results that that is unique to Apple I
actually haven't seen anyone else yet no
no one else no one else is doing that
now finally Apple's App Store has gained
the ability to update apps in the
background which it's been lacking for a
while and other operating systems on
mobile have actually had this ability
for a while so that's good that they've
gotten this and also iTunes radio which
is a lot closer to a Pandora than it is
to a Spotify or Google Play Music all
access the model the subscription model
and the way they're using it that you
can't see other items in your queue you
can't see you know what your next song
is going to be played is going to be
it's free with ads it's very very very
similar to Pandora internet radio and
that's where the idea for iTunes radio
originated so there you go I also got a
kick out of the extra feature slide
during the WWDC keynote which showed
things like notification sync which also
recently just came to android and night
mode for maps which the Google Maps app
in iOS also has and FaceTime audio and
the best part about that was right after
they described in great detail the
ability to make FaceTime audio calls
over Wi-Fi they flashed to a dude in the
audience wearing a Skype t-shirt who
looked particularly speechless at that
point I think it was probably probably
playing that really really well we had
the camera on him the whole time waiting
for his reaction so that was worth that
was pretty much golden reaction
priceless so at the end of the day iOS 7
features come from everywhere Android
features come from everywhere windows
features come from everywhere it's not
even close to it being a blatant copy
except for maybe Safari but honestly
they come from all over the place and we
should be good because like we
there are plenty of awesome features
that are too awesome not to be shared
Steve Jobs once very famously quoted
Picasso for saying this and I'll let you
listen to it yourself
I mean Picasso had a saying he said good
artists copy great artists steal
and we have you know always been
shameless about stealing great ideas and
I'm sure behind closed doors pretty much
every major tech company has had a CEO
say something along the same lines so
you know enjoy it welcome to the party
iOS users welcome to the party the
notification party whatever you want to
call the new iOS 7 features party
because you know what without iOS in the
first place we wouldn't have had a ton
of the features that we're seeing on
other operating systems so the sharing
goes all around and now you know where
iOS 7's new features come from either
way thank you for watching this video
feel free to share it with your friends
I know it's a long video but if you made
it this far
definitely the thumbs up below and if
subscribe if you want to see more like
this either way like I said thanks for
watching and I will talk to you guys in
the next one basically
[Music]